Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On September 20, 1992, New South Wales police officers gathered under the eucalyptus trees in the rugged depths of Balingalo State Forest, establishing the crime scene in what appeared to be a double homicide. The gravesite was located a significant distance from the Hume Highway, branching off from
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1992年9月20日，新南威尔士州警察局的警官们聚集在巴兰戈洛国家森林（Balingalo State Forest）崎岖深处桉树下的桉树林中，在一处疑似双重谋杀案的现场设立了犯罪现场。墓地距离休姆高速公路（Hume Highway）有相当一段距离，从
the motorway down a bumpy, red-dust road, bordered by 30-metre-high pine trees. Once the kilometres of pine plantations reached an end, the terrain transformed into dense bushland, intersected by a series of narrow fire trails. This area was only accessible on foot or via vehicles designed specifically to go off-road, meaning the killer had gone to great lengths to take his victims off track and likely owned or had access to a four-wheel drive. Items of clothing and jewelry found in proximity to the bodies indicated there was a strong chance one of the victims was Joanne Walters, the 22-year-old Welsh backpacker who was last
该高速公路分流出去，沿着一条颠簸的、铺满红土的路前行，路边环绕着30米高的松树。当数公里的松树人工林走到尽头时，地形变成了茂密的灌木丛，并被一系列狭窄的消防小径纵横交错地切断。这个区域只能步行或乘坐专为越野设计的车辆进入，这意味着凶手煞费苦心地将受害者带离了常规路线，并且很可能拥有一辆四轮驱动车或能够使用此类车辆。在尸体附近发现的衣物和首饰表明，其中一名受害者极有可能是乔安妮·沃尔特斯（Joanne Walters），这位22岁的威尔士背包客上一次
seen leaving Sydney's King's Cross District five months earlier. If this initial conjecture proved accurate, it raised the strong possibility that the second victim could be Joanne's travelling companion, 21-year-old English backpacker Caroline Clark. Both women had disappeared in April 1992 after telling friends and family they planned on hitchhiking south from Sydney towards Victoria before making their way up to Western Australia to commence fruit-picking work. Efforts to locate the two missing women at the time they vanished were unsuccessful.
被人看到是在五个月前离开悉尼的国王十字区（King's Cross District）。如果最初的这种推测被证明是准确的，这就极大地增加了第二名受害者可能是乔安妮的同行伙伴、21岁的英国背包客卡洛琳·克拉克（Caroline Clark）的可能性。这两名女性在1992年4月失踪，此前她们曾告诉朋友和家人，她们计划从悉尼向南搭便车前往维多利亚州，然后再前往西澳大利亚州开始摘果子的工作。在她们失踪当时，搜寻这两名失踪女性的努力并未成功。
Not a single trace of either Joanne or Caroline was ever found. Given their heavily decomposed state, the human remains couldn't be identified until further forensic testing was conducted. With thousands of missing people in Australia at the time, police were hesitant to draw any immediate conclusions. A police spokesperson fronted the media, saying, Police aren't ruling out anything at this stage and will be looking at all avenues to try to identify the bodies.
没有找到任何关于乔安妮或卡洛琳的蛛丝马迹。鉴于尸体高度腐烂，在进行进一步法医检测之前，这些人类遗骸无法被确认身份。当时澳大利亚有数千名失踪人员，警方对过早得出任何结论持谨慎态度。一名警方发言人在媒体面前表示，警方在这个阶段没有排除任何可能性，并将调查所有途径以试图确认尸体的身份。
There is nothing at this stage to suggest that it is Joanne and Caroline, but of course we will be looking at missing persons files to try to find something. Two days later, on September 22, dental records provided by the parents of Joanne and Caroline confirmed the remains uncovered in Balingalo were indeed their daughters. Joanne's father, Ray Walters, told the media, This sentiment was shared by Caroline's father, Ian Clark, who said, Forensic experts determined Joanne and Caroline's remains had been in Balingalo since April, meaning the pair were killed shortly after they went missing.
现阶段没有任何迹象表明这就是乔安妮和卡洛琳，但我们当然会查阅失踪人口档案来试着找到一些线索。两天后的9月22日，由乔安妮和卡洛琳的父母提供的牙科记录证实，在巴兰戈洛发掘出的遗骸确实是他们的女儿。乔安妮的父亲雷·沃尔特斯（Ray Walters）告诉媒体，卡洛琳的父亲伊恩·克拉克（Ian Clark）也表达了这种情感，他说，法医专家确定乔安妮和卡洛琳的遗骸自4月起就一直在巴兰戈洛，这意味着两人在失踪后不久就被杀害了。
Autopsies revealed both women had fallen victim to what police described as ferocious and sustained attacks. The lack of defensive wounds indicated they were both restrained and remained bound throughout their ordeal. Joanne Walters had upwards of 14 stab wounds throughout her torso. She had been gagged using three strips of material which appeared to have been torn from a size 41 men's shirt, tied in an over-under pullknot. A garot-like device used for strangulation lay on the ground nearby.
尸检显示，这两名女性都是警方所描述的凶猛且持续袭击的受害者。缺乏防御性伤口表明，她们在整个受虐过程中都被限制行动且一直被捆绑。乔安妮·沃尔特斯的躯干上有14处以上的刺伤。她被用三条布条塞住嘴巴，这些布条似乎是从一件41码的男士衬衫上撕下来的，并打了一个上下交错的拉结。一个用于勒死人的类似绞索的装置掉落在附近的地上。
Caroline Clark's body lay 30 metres from Joanne's, her head wrapped in a sweatshirt riddled with bullet holes. Ten bullets had penetrated her skull from close range, and she had also sustained a knife wound through her back. Ballistic experts determined the bullets were shot from a .22 calibre rifle. Seven bullets were recovered from Caroline's skull, and the remaining three were found in the soil beneath her remains. Women spent Winchester brand cartridge cases were found three metres from Caroline's body.
卡洛琳·克拉克的尸体距离乔安妮的尸体30米远，她的头部包裹着一件布满了弹孔的运动衫。十颗子弹近距离射穿了她的头骨，她的背部也遭受了刀伤。弹道专家确定这些子弹是由一支.22口径步枪发射的。从卡洛琳的头骨中取出了七颗子弹，其余三颗在她的遗骸下方的土壤中被找到。在距离卡洛琳尸体三米远的地方发现了温彻斯特（Winchester）品牌的女性用过的子弹壳。
Discarded five metres from Caroline's body were six cigarette butts. Five were her preferred brand, with the brand of the sixth unknown. It couldn't be established whether it was Caroline or her killer who had smoked the cigarettes, but if they were all inhaled by the perpetrator, the amount of time that would take them to do so meant they would have spent an unusually long time at the crime scene. An area of trampled-down bush nearby was now showing signs of regrowth, suggesting some of the attack may have occurred there.
在距离卡洛琳尸体五米远的地方丢弃着六个烟头。五个是她偏爱的品牌，第六个品牌的烟头未知。目前无法确定是卡洛琳还是她的凶手抽了这些烟，但如果这些烟全部由凶手吸食，那么完成这一过程所需的时间意味着他们在犯罪现场逗留了异常长的时间。附近一块被踩踏过的灌木丛现在显示出重新生长的迹象，这表明部分袭击可能发生在那个地方。
40 metres away, investigators came across several bricks circling a small pile of ash, the remnants of a makeshift fire pit. The crime scene was a considerable distance from the main road, leading investigators to believe the killer was local to the area and had familiarity of Belangelo's layout, including the secluded areas less travelled. No possibilities were ruled out, with police considering many scenarios, including that more than one killer was involved, and that there were more bodies hidden in the forest. Detectives from the New South Wales Homicide Squad joined forces
40米外，调查人员偶然发现了几块砖头围着一小堆灰烬，这是一个临时火坑的残余。犯罪现场距离主路相当远，这让调查人员相信凶手是当地人，并且熟悉巴兰戈洛的布局，包括那些人迹罕至的偏僻区域。没有任何可能性被排除，警方考虑了多种情况，包括有不止一名凶手参与，以及森林里还藏有更多尸体。新南威尔士州凶杀案调查组的侦探们与当地警官联手
with local officers to conduct a full-scale search of the crime scene and its surrounds. More than 100 police officers, rescue workers and sniffer dogs tracked the Belangelo State Forest, as divers scoured dams on nearby private properties. But the sheer size of the forest, which consisted of gullies, steep hills, creeks, thick trees and dense shrubbery, made the search a monumental task. Despite the extensive efforts of everyone involved, nothing else of significance was uncovered. News of the murders of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark filled the families of other missing
对犯罪现场及其周边进行了全面搜查。100多名警察、救援人员和警犬在巴兰戈洛国家森林中搜寻，潜水员则在附近私人物业的水坝中搜寻。但是，由峡谷、陡峭山丘、小溪、茂密的树木和浓密的灌木丛组成的森林的巨大规模，使搜寻工作成为了一项极其艰巨的任务。尽管所有相关人员都作出了巨大努力，但没有发现其他具有重大意义的东西。乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克遇害的消息令其他失踪背包客的家属
backpackers with dread. Norbert Habschied's sister, Anya, had disappeared with her boyfriend, Gabor Neugebauer from Sydney, near nine months earlier. Norbert stated, We are very sad that these girls were found dead, because the same thing could have happened to Anya and to Gabor. Investigators did look into the files of other missing backpackers, but failed to find anything to suggest that any met a similar fate to that of Joanne and Caroline.
充满了恐惧。诺伯特·哈布希德（Norbert Habschied）的姐姐安雅（Anya）在近九个月前和她的男友加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔（Gabor Neugebauer）一起从悉尼失踪。诺伯特表示，这些女孩被发现死亡，我们感到非常难过，因为同样的事情也可能发生在安雅和加博尔身上。调查人员确实调查了其他失踪背包客的档案，但未能找到任何迹象表明他们遭遇了与乔安妮和卡洛琳类似的命运。
As such, police wound down their search of Belangelo, and instead focused on finding the killer. A police spokesperson told the Australian newspaper, The search has covered a wide enough area for us to dismiss speculation that there are other bodies. But more graves is obviously not what this search is for, as to find evidence on the two girls found murdered. The task force was established with 12 detectives assigned to work on the case full time, but
因此，警方缩减了对巴兰戈洛的搜寻范围，转而集中精力寻找凶手。一名警方发言人告诉《澳大利亚人报》，这次搜查的范围足够广泛，足以让我们驳斥关于还有其他尸体的猜测。但找到更多的坟墓显然不是这次搜查的目的，而是为了在两名被谋杀的女孩身上找到证据。专案组成立了，指派了12名侦探全职负责此案，但
their work was cut out for them as they had very little to go on. Just weeks into their investigation, detectives conceded they had virtually no leads. Belangelo was frequented by residents of the nearby small Southern Highlands town of Bowerall. Their forest backdrop provided them with the opportunity to engage in an abundance of outdoor activities including bush walks, picnics, camping, and four-wheel driving. Yet, upon the chilling discovery of human remains within Belangelo's depths, many now vowed to never return. One Bowerall resident remarked,
他们的任务异常艰巨，因为他们掌握的线索少之又少。调查开始仅几周后，侦探们就承认他们几乎没有任何线索。巴兰戈洛经常有附近南部高地小镇鲍勒尔（Bowerall）的居民光顾。他们身后的森林背景为他们提供了参与丰富户外活动的机会，包括丛林徒步、野餐、露营和四轮驱动越野。然而，随着在巴兰戈洛深处骇人听闻地发现人类遗骸，许多人现在发誓再也不回去了。一位鲍勒尔居民评论道，
I can't believe there's such a peaceful place could be the scene of something so awful. One crime was virtually unheard of in Bowerall, and speculation that the killer could live locally led members of the community to yie each other with suspicion. One resident said, For all I know, it could be anybody that you drink with at the pub. It could be anybody you pass in the main street. Just how are we to know?
我简直不敢相信这样一个宁静的地方会发生如此可怕的事情。这样的罪行在鲍勒尔几乎闻所未闻，关于凶手可能是当地人的猜测使得社区成员开始用怀疑的眼光互相打量。一位居民说，据我所知，凶手可能是你在酒吧里一起喝酒的任何人。可能是你在主街上擦肩而过的任何人都可能是。我们到底该如何得知？
On October 4, two weeks after Joanne Walters and Caroline Clarke were found, mourners gathered in the remote area of Belangelo for what the Walters family titled, a service of serenity. Relatives of both young women were in attendance, as were members of the local community. The Walters and Clarke families insisted the event wasn't a funeral or memorial service, but a way to thank the Australian people for their support, and to recognise the efforts of police and the Bowerall community in finding their daughters. It also aimed to expunge the evil that had taken place in the forest, to ensure Joanne
10月4日，在乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克被找到两周后，哀悼者聚集在巴兰戈洛偏远地区，参加沃尔特斯家族所称的“宁静追悼会”。两位年轻女性的亲属以及当地社区成员都出席了。沃尔特斯和克拉克家族坚称，这次活动不是葬礼或纪念仪式，而是一种感谢澳大利亚人民支持的方式，并以此表彰警方和鲍勒尔社区在寻找他们女儿时付出的努力。此举也旨在驱除发生在森林中的邪恶，以确保乔安妮
and Caroline's souls could rest in peace. An overcast sky stretched above the forest, drizzling rain down on the crowds as they let candles and laid wreaths. A Welsh flag was draped over the site where Joanne was found, and some 30 metres away, a Union jack flag lay where Caroline was discovered. The rain began to ease as Anglican Minister Father Stephen Gray began his opening address, declaring, We have come here to this place, a place where something wicked happened, to call on the
和卡洛琳的灵魂能够安息。阴沉的天空笼罩在森林上空，当人群点燃蜡烛并敬献花圈时，细雨绵绵地落在他们身上。一面威尔士国旗盖在发现乔安妮的地方，大约30米外，一面英国国旗则铺在发现卡洛琳的地方。随着圣公会牧师斯蒂芬·格雷（Stephen Gray）神父开始他的开幕致辞，雨势开始减弱，他宣告道：我们来到这个地方，一个发生过邪恶事情的地方，来呼唤上帝的力量，好让这个地方再次恢复平静。
power of God, so this place will be peaceful again. Members of the Sydney Welsh Choir sang a popular folk song from their homeland, Mavunwi. At the conclusion of the service, they sang, You'll Never Walk Alone, during which the clouds parted, and the sun shone down upon the forest. Following the service, Joanne's father said, I just couldn't leave without thanking the Australian people for how they've helped us. To have gone home without this service would have been leaving something out. Now we're putting this area back to how it was, and putting the girls to rest.
悉尼威尔士合唱团的成员们演唱了他们家乡的一首流行民歌《Mavunwi》。在仪式结束时，他们演唱了《你永独行》（You'll Never Walk Alone），期间云开雾散，阳光洒满森林。仪式结束后，乔安妮的父亲说，我只是不能在不感谢澳大利亚人民如何帮助过我们的情况下离开。如果连这个仪式都没有就回家，那就好像有所遗漏。现在我们要把这个地区恢复原貌，让女孩们入土为安。
In what was considered to be one of the most widespread and exhaustive investigations conducted by the NSW police force, the search for Joanne and Caroline's killer resulted in thousands of lines of inquiry across Australia and the UK, with more than 500 people formally interviewed. Detective Inspector Bob Godden, who was a leading Joanne and Caroline's murder inquiry, stated, Our investigations have covered literally millions of square kilometres both here in Australia and overseas. Detectives have travelled extensively throughout NSW and have made inquiries in areas such as Wagga Wagga, Narendra, Wentworth, Naurar and the Southern Highlands.
这被认为是新州警察部队进行的最广泛、最详尽的调查之一，对乔安妮和卡洛琳凶手的搜寻引发了全澳大利亚和英国的数千条调查线索，正式面谈了500多人。负责乔安妮和卡洛琳谋杀案调查的侦探督察鲍勃·戈登（Bob Godden）表示，我们的调查实际上已经覆盖了澳大利亚国内和海外数百万平方公里的面积。侦探们在新州各地进行了广泛的旅行，并在沃加沃加（Wagga Wagga）、纳兰德拉（Narrandera）、温特沃思（Wentworth）、诺拉（Nowra）和南部高地等地区进行了调查。
NSW police have also travelled to Victoria, Queensland and South Australia as part of their investigations. I can assure the community that dozens of experienced detectives have poured thousands of hours into this murder investigation, and we remain confident of achieving a breakthrough. Despite these efforts, the investigation struggled to make any considerable progress, prompting the NSW state government to offer a $100,000 reward. But the monetary offer did little to rejuvenate the languishing investigation. The task force continued its inquiries, but what began with a team of 12 detectives working
新州警方作为调查的一部分，还前往了维多利亚州、昆士兰州和南澳大利亚州。我可以向社区保证，数十名经验丰富的侦探已经为这起谋杀案倾注了数千小时的心血，我们仍然对取得突破充满信心。尽管付出了这些努力，调查仍难以取得任何实质性进展，这促使新州州政府悬赏10万澳元。但金钱悬赏对停滞不前的调查并没有起到多大振作作用。专案组继续进行调查，但最初由12名侦探组成的团队全职
on the case full-time was reduced to just three. On October 5, 1993, a little over one year since Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark were found, a local man named De Bruis Pryor was driving through Balingalo in search of firewood. This was something he had always done, but ever since the murders, Bruis remained extra observant while collecting wood on the off chance he came across anything police had missed during their search. On this particular day, Bruis drove along the upper end of the Longacre fire trail. He was in a remote area of dense scrub, located approximately 500 metres from where Joanne
负责此案，现在已经缩减到只有三人。1993年10月5日，在乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克被发现一年多一点后，一名叫德布鲁伊斯·普赖尔（De Bruis Pryor）的当地男子正开车穿过巴兰戈洛寻找柴火。这是他一直以来都会做的事情，但自从发生谋杀案以来，布鲁伊斯在收集木材时一直保持着格外细致的观察，以防万一偶然发现任何警方在搜查时漏掉的东西。在这一天，布鲁伊斯沿着朗阿克消防小径（Longacre fire trail）的上端开车。他身处一个密林丛生的偏远地区，距离乔安妮
and Caroline's remains were found. He parked his car and ventured off the fire trail on foot, heading deep into Balingalo's rugged terrain. After walking inward for about 100 metres, Bruis noticed what appeared to be a human femur bone on the ground. He continued through the bush for about 20 metres, where he made another startling discovery, several more bones, and a human skull. Bruis raised the alarm at the closest rangers hut, and the police were contacted.
和卡洛琳遗骸被发现的地方大约500米。他把车停好，步行离开消防小径，深入巴兰戈洛崎岖的地形。向内步行大约100米后，布鲁伊斯注意到地上似乎有一根人类的大腿骨。他在灌木丛中继续前行了大约20米，在那里他有了另一个惊人的发现：几块更多的骨头和一个人类头骨。布鲁伊斯在最近的护林员小屋拉响了警报，警方随即被联系。
Upon their arrival, Bruis led them to his discovery. A cursory search of the area uncovered more bones, teeth, and decaying women's clothing hidden under piles of sticks and bracken. A silver chain, crucifix and a bracelet containing small stones were located near the bones. Further away, a pair of pantyhose were found with the lower ends tied into slip knots, having clearly been used as a restraint. A piece of decomposed fabric was thought to have been used as a gag. Four lengths of red and yellow electrical tape were also recovered from the scene.
他们到达后，布鲁伊斯带领他们来到了他发现的地方。对该区域的粗略搜查发现更多的骨头、牙齿以及藏在树枝和蕨类植物堆下的腐烂女装。在骨头附近发现了银链、十字架和一条带有小石头的手链。在更远的地方，发现了一条连裤袜，其下端打成了活结，显然曾被用作束缚工具。一块腐烂的织物被认为是用来堵嘴的。现场还回收了四段红黄相间的电线。
Two hours later, just 22 metres west from the first set of remains, police came across a pair of men's sand shoes, visible under a large pile of sticks and branches at the base of a tree. Under the pile was the skeleton of a second body. Parallels were immediately drawn between this double homicide crime scene and the one established in the same forest the year prior. Both sets of victims were located in close proximity and had been covered in a similar manner by forest debris.
两小时后，就在距离第一处遗骸以西仅22米的地方，警方在一棵树基部的一大堆木棍和树枝下发现了一双隐约可见的男士沙滩鞋。这堆东西下面是一具第二具尸体的骨架。人们立即将这个双重谋杀犯罪现场与前一年在同一座森林中设立的犯罪现场进行了对比。两组受害者都被发现在彼此相距不远的地方，并以类似的方式被森林残骸覆盖。
400 metres from the newly discovered remains was a tree trunk peppered with nine bullets, eight of which were too damaged to be identified, but a ninth which was confirmed to have come from a .22 calibre rifle, the same weapon used against Caroline Clark. Both crime scenes were positioned close to the remnants of old campsites. In the case of the second crime scene, the campsite was 100 metres away from where the victims lay and included a fire pit built from bush rocks. Investigators considered whether the killer had camped out with these victims before turning on them or had stayed in the area after the slayings.
在刚发现的遗骸40米外，有一根树干上布满了九颗子弹，其中八颗损毁严重无法辨认，但第九颗被证实来自一支.22口径步枪，这与针对卡洛琳·克拉克使用的是同一把武器。两个犯罪现场都靠近旧露营地的遗迹。在第二个犯罪现场的情况下，露营地距离受害者躺着的地方有100米远，其中包括一个用丛林石块搭建的火坑。调查人员考虑凶手是否在对这些受害者动手之前曾与他们一起露营，或者在行凶后一直留在该地区。
Based on the remoteness and proximity of the two crime scenes, authorities believed the same killer was responsible for all four deaths and that they were still certain they were dealing with a local who was familiar with the forest. Superintendent Clyde Small, quote, you wouldn't expect a person just a driving past to go to these depths. The recently uncovered skeletal remains were sent for post-mortem examination and identification. Meanwhile, speculation ran rife as to who they might be, with theories centralised on missing German backpackers Gabor Neugebauer and his girlfriend Anja Habschied, who were
基于两个犯罪现场的偏远和接近程度，当局认为同一个凶手对这四起死亡事件负有责任，并且他们仍然确信他们面对的是一个熟悉该森林的当地人。小克莱德总督察（Superintend Clyde Small）引述道，你不会指望一个只是开车路过的人会走到这么深的地方。最近发现的人类骨骸被送去进行尸检和身份识别。与此同时，关于他们可能是谁的猜测甚嚣尘上，理论集中在失踪的德国背包客加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔和他的女友安雅·哈布希德身上，他们
last seen leaving their hostel in Sydney just over a year and a half earlier. Police expressed their opinion that the remains appear to have been in the forest for approximately 12 months. Further validating theories, they were those of the German couple. Yet, forensic testing revealed the remains had in fact spent close to five years in the bushland, ruling out any possibility they were Gabor and Anja. As investigators waited for results of the post-mortem, they checked missing persons records to determine whether any other foreign backpackers had disappeared from New South
最后一次被人看到离开他们在悉尼的旅舍是在一年半多以前。警方表达了他们的看法，即遗骸在森林中似乎已经大约有12个月了。这进一步证实了他们是那对德国夫妇的理论。然而，法医检测显示，这些遗骸实际上在灌木丛中度过了将近五年的时间，排除了他们是加博尔和安雅的任何可能性。正当调查人员等待尸检结果时，他们检查了失踪人口档案，以确定大约五年前是否有其他外国背包客从新南威尔士州失踪。
Wales around five years ago. Days later, both bodies were positively identified, and it wasn't at all who many were expecting. Given the media attention had focused primarily on missing international backpackers, not as much had been mentioned about the December 1989 disappearance of 19-year-old Australian couple James Gibson and Deborah Everest. They had last been seen in the Sydney suburb of Surrey Hills, with the intention to hitch hike south to Aubrey. Deborah Everest had a broken jaw and fractured skull, sustained by a solid object.
几天后，两具尸体得到了确凿的身份确认，而这根本不是许多人所预期的那样。鉴于媒体的注意力主要集中在失踪的国际背包客上，对于1989年12月19岁的澳大利亚情侣詹姆斯·吉布森（James Gibson）和黛博拉·埃弗里斯特（Deborah Everest）的失踪，报道则没有那么多。他们最后一次被 S-urrey Hills 的悉尼郊区被看到，打算搭便车向南前往奥尔伯里（Aubrey）。黛博拉·埃弗里斯特有一处下颌骨折和头骨骨折，是由坚硬物体造成的。
Such blunt force trauma would have led to unconsciousness, and possibly even caused a hemorrhage, brain damage, or death. Several deep gashes across her skull were caused by a large knife or sword like object. Markings on the rib area of her back were caused by a 30mm wide blade. James Gibson was found in the fetal position, having been stabbed in a frenzied manner seven times throughout his body. Like Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark, neither James nor Deborah had defensive wounds, indicating they too were restrained.
这种钝力外伤会导致意识丧失，甚至可能引起出血、脑损伤或死亡。她头骨上的几处深长伤口是由一把大刀或剑类物体造成的。她背部肋骨区域的印记是由一把30毫米宽的刀刃造成的。詹姆斯·吉布森被发现时呈胎儿姿势，全身被疯狂地刺了七刀。就像乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克一样，詹姆斯和黛博拉都没有防御性伤口，这表明他们同样被束缚了。
Detectives returned their focus to James Gibson's 35mm Ricoh brand camera, which had been found on Galston Gorge Road on December 31, 1989, one day after the couple went missing. Galston Gorge Road was located 150km north of Balingalo, in the opposite direction to James and Deborah's intended destination near Aubrey. James's backpack, which had also been found on Galston Gorge Road months after the couple's disappearance, contained pine needles, despite there being no pine trees in that area. This led investigators to believe James and Deborah had been killed in Balingalo State Forest on December 30, 1989, the day they were last seen alive.
侦探们将注意力重新集中在詹姆斯·吉布森的35毫米理光（Ricoh）牌相机上，该相机于1989年12月31日（即这对情侣失踪一天后）在加尔斯顿峡谷路（Galston Gorge Road）被发现。加尔斯顿峡谷路位于巴兰戈洛以北150公里处，与詹姆斯和黛博拉预定前往奥尔伯里附近的目的地方向相反。詹姆斯的背包在这对情侣失踪几个月后也在加尔斯顿峡谷路被找到，里面含有松针，尽管该地区并没有松树。这使得调查人员相信，詹姆斯和黛博拉于1989年12月30日（他们最后一次被看到活着的日子）在巴兰戈洛国家森林被杀害。
The killer had then gone to considerable efforts to dump James's belongings along Galston Gorge Road the next day, perhaps in an attempt to mislead police. Upon hearing news that James and Deborah were found, the Gibson and Everest families were left shattered, having maintained hope throughout the years that their children were still alive. James's sister Mary Ann told the media, James was such a good person, he was very, very talented and good fun and gentle, the wrong sort of person to meet a violent end. A town meeting was held in Bowerl, where local police warned the 120 residents in attendance about the dangers of hitchhiking and jogging or walking alone.
凶手随后费了很大力气在第二天沿着加尔斯顿峡谷路抛弃了詹姆斯的物品，也许是企图误导警方。听到詹姆斯和黛博拉被找到的消息后，吉布森和埃弗里斯特家族心碎欲绝，他们多年来一直抱有孩子们还活着的希望。詹姆斯的妹妹玛丽·安（Mary Ann）告诉媒体，詹姆斯是一个非常好的人，他非常、非常有才华、很有趣而且温和，是最不应该遭遇暴力结局的人。鲍勒尔举行了一场城镇会议，当地警察向出席会议的120名居民警告了搭便车、慢跑或独自走路的危险。
Terrified locals bombarded police with questions, desperate to know whether they believed more victims lay undiscovered in the forest. All the while, attending investigators inconspicuously scanned the crowd, looking for anyone who stood out as suspicious. The parents of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark made an appeal to the people of Bowerl via video, pleading for anyone with information to come forward, emphasising the importance of finding their daughter's backpacks which were still missing and possibly held significant clues. Deborah Everest's brother Tim said, If anyone knows anything about the murders, how would they feel if it was their sister,
吓坏了的当地人向警察抛出各种问题，急切地想知道他们是否相信森林里还有更多受害者未被发现。与此同时，出席的调查人员不动声色地扫视着人群，寻找任何表现得可疑的人。乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克的父母通过视频向鲍勒尔的人民发出呼吁，恳求任何有线索的人站出来，强调找到他们女儿们背包的重要性，这些背包仍然失踪，可能包含重要的线索。黛博拉·埃弗里斯特的兄弟蒂姆（Tim）说，如果任何人知道关于这些谋杀案的任何事情，如果是他们的姐姐、
mother, daughter, brother or father that this had happened to? Think of it like that. Fear gripped the Bowerl community, with many citizens stating they were too scared to leave the house. Homes once kept open by trusting residents were now locked up, with locals hesitant to move about at night alone. For one regional store, Highland's security, business doubled as the sales of locks and alarms increased. To help solve the murders of Joanne Walters, Caroline Clark, James Gibson and Deborah Everest, the New South Wales police force established Task Force Air, initially consisting of 15 detectives, two intelligence analysts and several forensic investigators,
母亲、女儿、兄弟或父亲遭遇了这种事，他们会作何感想？就这样去想吧。恐惧笼罩着鲍勒尔社区，许多市民表示他们害怕得不敢出门。曾经被信任的居民敞开的家门现在锁上了，当地人对独自在夜间出行感到犹豫不决。对于一家区域商店“高原安保（Highland's Security）”来说，随着锁具和警报器销量的增加，业务翻了一番。为了协助侦破乔安妮·沃尔特斯、卡洛琳·克拉克、詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里斯特的谋杀案，新南威尔士州警察部队成立了空气特别行动组（Task Force Air），最初由15名侦探、两名情报分析员和几名法医调查人员组成，
all led by Superintendent Clive Small. The well-respected astute detective was renowned for his investigation into the 1987 shooting of undercover New South Wales police officer Michael Drury. Small was also responsible for reviewing the rape and kidnapping charges laid against former New South Wales police detective superintendent Harry Blackburn. Small discovered evidence that proved Blackburn's innocence, thus saving him from being sent to prison for crimes he didn't commit. The hunt for the killer presented serious challenges for Task Force Air. A considerable amount of time had passed since the four murders, and police had so far failed to uncover any evidence to point towards a prime suspect. Small assembled a tough,
全部由克莱夫·小（Clive Small）总督察领导。这位备受尊敬、精明的侦探以调查1987年卧底新南威尔士州警察迈克尔·德鲁里（Michael Drury）遭枪击案而闻名。小督察还负责审查对前新南威尔士州警察侦探总督察哈里·布莱克本（Harry Blackburn）提出的强奸和绑架指控。小督察发现了证明布莱克本清白的证据，从而使他免于因未曾犯下的罪行而被送进监狱。对凶手的搜捕给空气特别行动组带来了严峻的挑战。距离这四起谋杀案已经过去了相当长的时间，警方到目前为止还没能发现任何指向主要嫌疑人的证据。小督察组建了一支坚韧、
reliable team of detectives whom he trusted. Some had previously worked on the investigation into notorious serial killer John Wayne Glover. Small fronted the media and publicly declared that they were likely hunting down a serial killer or killers. Quote, There are some similarities, and to the indications are we're heading in the direction of a common offender or offenders. We are very conscious of the fact the two sets of bodies were found in a straight line 500 to 600 meters apart. The investigation will be extended to look at other missing backpackers and missing persons. Warnings about the dangers of hitchhiking were issued, with Small pleading with travelers not to accept rides from strangers under any circumstances.
可靠的侦探团队，他信任他们。其中一些人曾参与调查臭名昭著的连环杀手约翰·韦恩·格洛弗（John Wayne Glover）。小督察面对媒体公开宣布，他们很可能在追捕一名或多名连环杀手。引述道，存在一些相似之处，迹象表明我们正朝着共同的罪犯或罪犯的方向前进。我们非常清楚两组尸体被发现在一条直线上，相距500到600米的事实。调查将扩大到寻找其他失踪的背包客和失踪人员。发出了关于搭便车危险的警告，小督察恳求旅行者在任何情况下都不要接受陌生人的搭车。
His warnings seemed to fall on deaf ears, with several backpackers telling journalists for the Sydney Morning Herald the murders wouldn't deter them from hitchhiking, as they were on tight budgets, and it was the cheapest mode of transport. Task Force Air's first major assignment was to develop a plan to conduct the most thorough search possible of Balangelo State Forest. The team used satellite imagery to identify any changes in the density of the vegetation since the late 1980s in the hope it would help locate potential burial sites. GPS was used to plot points on maps and mark locations where bodies and evidence had so far been located, while a command post was established in the forest and staffed around the clock.
他的警告似乎没有起作用，几位背包客告诉《悉尼先驱晨报》的记者，这些谋杀案不会阻止他们搭便车，因为他们手头拮据，而且这是最便宜的交通方式。空气特别行动组的第一个重大任务是制定一项计划，对巴兰戈洛国家森林进行尽可能彻底的搜查。该团队使用卫星图像来识别自20世纪80年代末以来植被密度的任何变化，希望这能有助于定位潜在的埋尸地点。使用全球定位系统（GPS）在地图上标出点位并标记迄今为止发现尸体和证据的位置，同时在森林中设立了一个全天候有专人值守的指挥所。
Forensic investigators were on standby to attend any newly discovered crime scenes, which police were certain existed. Each day, buses containing hundreds of police and state emergency service volunteers from surrounding regions arrived to the forest, working in teams of 40 as they traversed the scrub in search lines, sometimes on their hands and knees. Two cadaver dogs specially trained to work in rough terrain were also called in. An area extending five square kilometers outwards from the known crime scenes was scoured, with teams also retracing areas covered in previous surges. Anytime a person located an item of interest, they were advised to yell,
法医调查人员随时待命，准备前往任何新发现的犯罪现场，警方确信这些现场是存在的。每天，载有数百名来自周边地区的警察和州紧急服务志愿者的公共汽车抵达森林，他们以40人为一组，有时手脚并用地在灌木丛中排成搜索线穿行。两只专门在恶劣地形中工作的搜尸犬也被调来。搜索范围扩大到距离已知犯罪现场向外延伸五平方公里的区域，团队还重新搜查了先前突击搜查中涵盖的区域。每当有人发现感兴趣的物品时，他们会被建议大喊：
find, after which the team leader of the group would assess the item and make contact with the command post. A police spokesperson provided the media with an update on the search, advising, we have found nothing so far to suggest that there are more bodies out there, but we certainly can't discount the possibility that there are. At the moment, we are consolidating the information that has come in to the investigative unit and are sifting through that for leads. One of the only pieces of physical evidence investigators had that could link them directly to the killer or killers were the recovered bullets and cartridge cases that were determined to have been fired from a .22 caliber rifle.
找到了，之后该组的团队负责人会评估该物品并与指挥所取得联系。一名警方发言人向媒体提供了搜查的最新进展，建议道，到目前为止，我们还没有发现任何迹象表明外面还有更多的尸体，但我们当然不能排除这种可能性。目前，我们正在巩固进入调查单位的信息，并从中筛选线索。调查人员掌握的能够将他们直接与凶手或凶手联系起来的唯一物理证据之一就是回收的子弹和弹壳，经确定这些子弹是从.22口径步枪中发射的。
The search to find the knife or knives used in the attacks was a far more difficult task, as forensic experts were not yet able to distinguish whether the same one or several were used in the slayings. Superintendent Small stated, you don't have as many opportunities to chase up a knife as you do a firearm. Therefore, locating the firearm and its owner became a major facet of Task Force Air's investigation. Superintendent Clive Small requested anyone who owned a .22 caliber rifle to come forward to eliminate themselves from the investigation, as detectives spoke to gun dealers within the barrel area. Plans were made to question all 2,000 licensed gun owners in the southern
寻找袭击中使用的刀具是一项困难得多的任务，因为法医专家尚无法区分在杀戮中使用的是同一把刀还是多把刀。小督察小克莱德表示，你追查一把刀的机会不如追查一支枪那么多。因此，定位火器及其所有者成为了空气特别行动组调查的一个主要方面。克莱夫·小总督察要求任何拥有.22口径步枪的人主动站出来以将自己排除在调查之外，同时侦探们与巴勒（Barrel）地区的枪械经销商进行了交谈。制定了对南部高地地区的全部2,000名持证枪主进行盘问的计划，并在需要时将搜查范围扩大到全国。
Highlands region and to extend the search nationwide if required. Every line of inquiry was followed up by Task Force Air, but with no major breakthroughs in the case, things were beginning to slow down in Balingolo. On the afternoon of November 1, 1993, four weeks after James Gibson and Deborah Everest were found, a group of police were asked to do one final sweep of their allocated area of the forest. The officers were exhausted and disheartened. They had been searching for close to a month straight and had yet to uncover anything of importance. Nevertheless, the group performed the sweep as directed, trawling in a single file in an area of bushland located approximately 40
空气特别行动组跟进了每一条调查线索，但由于案件没有重大突破，巴兰戈洛的情况开始放缓。1993年11月1日下午，在詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里斯特被找到四周后，一群警察被要求对他们分配的森林区域进行最后一次彻底清查。警官们精疲力竭、沮丧不已。他们已经连续搜查了近一个月，却还没有发现任何重要东西。尽管如此，该小组还是按指示进行了清查，在距离一条名为“矿工绝望（Miners Despair）”的消防小径大约40
meters off a fire trail known as Miners Despair. They were towards the outer limits of the designated search area, a few kilometers away from where the four bodies had been uncovered. As the officers inspected the rugged terrain and sifted through the fallen branches and foliage, one stopped in their tracks. They raced their hand in the air and yelled, Find. Forensic investigators cordoned off the area near the Miners Despair fire trail, where police uncovered more human skeletal remains, along with several personal items, including jewelry and coins. The bones were sent for forensic testing,
米的灌木丛区域单列排开艰难前行。他们正接近指定搜索区域的边缘地带，距离发现四具尸体的地方几公里远。当警官们检查崎岖的地形并穿过落下的树枝和树叶时，其中一人停下了脚步。他们将手举向空中并大喊：找到了。法医调查人员封锁了“矿工绝望”消防小径附近的区域，警方在那里发现了更多的人类骨骼遗骸，以及几件个人物品，包括珠宝和硬币。这些骨头被送去进行法医检测，
where dental records confirmed they belonged to missing German backpacker, 21-year-old Simone Schmidl. Simone had been missing for almost three years. She was last seen alive in January 1991, walking towards the Hume Highway with plans to hitchhike south to Melbourne. As in the case of several of the other victims found in Belangelo, Simone had been stabbed multiple times with extreme force. Her t-shirt was found 50 meters from her body with its front slashed open, along with a length of soft wire tied in the shape of a noose. Superintendent Clive Small fronted the media, confirming that police were of the opinion that Simone's killer was the same person responsible for the murders of James Gibson, Deborah Everest,
其中的牙科记录证实它们属于失踪的德国背包客、21岁的西蒙妮·施米德尔（Simone Schmidl）。西蒙妮已经失踪了将近三年。她最后一次被看到活着是在1991年1月，当时她正走向休姆高速公路，计划搭便车向南前往墨尔本。正如在巴兰戈洛发现的其他几位受害者的案件一样，西蒙妮曾遭到极端暴力的多次刺伤。她的T恤在距离她尸体50米的地方被发现，正面被划开，旁边还有一段打成绞索形状的软电线。克莱夫·小总督察面对媒体，确认警方认为西蒙妮的凶手与对詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗里斯特、
Joanne Walters, and Caroline Clark. Leading criminologist Professor Duncan Campbell from the Australian Institute of Criminology told The Age newspaper that it would be an unusual case if a serial killer was responsible for all slayings as, quote, they don't usually kill across genders and don't normally kill more than one person at a time. The search of Belangelo ramped up once again in what was shaping up to be one of the largest homicide investigations ever conducted in New South Wales. All five victims were found in the northmost region of the forest, and police concentrated their efforts on the three fire trails within the vicinity of the gravesites, long acre, miners' despair, and a tree cave.
乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克谋杀案负责的是同一个人。澳大利亚犯罪学研究所（Australian Institute of Criminology）的知名犯罪学家邓肯·坎贝尔（Duncan Campbell）教授向《时代报》（The Age）表示，如果由一名连环杀手对所有杀戮负责，这将是一个不寻常的案件，因为引用他的话，他们通常不会跨性别杀人，也不会通常一次杀死多个人。对巴兰戈洛的搜查再次加剧，这正在演变成新南威尔士州有史以来规模最大的凶杀案调查之一。所有五名受害者都被发现在森林的最北端，警方将精力集中在墓地附近的三个消防小径上：朗阿克（Long Acre）、矿工绝望（Miners' Despair）和树洞（Tree Cave）。
Three days later, on November 4, 1993, a police team was searching a rocky bluff approximately 30 metres from the Tree Cave fire trail, about one kilometre east from where Simone Schmiddle's remains were found. An officer spotted a women's brown sandal with a broken strap amongst the forest debris. A 10-metre walk onwards, underneath a stack of branches and next to a partially burned log, lay a human skeleton. The area was immediately silled off by forensic investigators who made another grim discovery just 50 metres away, where underneath a pile of logs, they found the remains of a second body. A plane ticket, shoes, a watch, and a jewellery were found close by, as was a bra with multiple stab marks, a pair of black leggings,
三天后的1993年11月4日，一个警察小分队正在搜查距离树洞消防小径约30米处的一处岩石峭壁，大约在西蒙妮·施米德尔遗骸被发现处以东一公里左右。一名警官在森林残骸中发现了一只断了带子的女性棕色凉鞋。向前步行10米，在成堆的树枝下一根半烧焦的木头旁，躺着一具人类骨架。该区域立即被法医调查人员封锁，他们在仅50米外有了另一个可怕的发现，在那里，在一堆圆木下面，他们找到了第二具尸体的遗骸。附近发现了飞机票、鞋子、手表和珠宝，还有带有多个刺痕的胸罩、一条黑色打底裤，
and pink jeans. Wrapped in underwear inside the jeans was a piece of pink coloured cloth, knotted in a V-shape reminiscent of the bandana-type masks worn by cowboys in movies. A homemade restraint made from black insulation tape, sash cord, and plastic electrical ties was also recovered, along with several other pieces of black electrical tape and a length of blue and yellow rope tied to form a 70-centimeter loop at one end and a 12-centimeter loop at the other. Dental records confirmed the identity of the remains to be those of missing German backpacker 21-year-old Gabor Neugebauer and his 20-year-old girlfriend Anja Habschied. The couple were last seen alive checking out of their hostel in Sydney's
和粉红色的牛仔裤。牛仔裤里面包裹着一块粉红色的布，打成了一个V形的结，让人想起电影中牛仔戴的班丹纳头巾式面具。现场还回收了一个用黑色绝缘胶带、窗帘绳和塑料电线扎带自制的束缚工具，以及几块其他的黑色电线胶带和一段蓝黄相间的绳子，绳子一端系成一个70厘米的环，另一端系成一个12厘米的环。牙科记录证实遗骸的身份是失踪的德国背包客、21岁的加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔和他的20岁女友安雅·哈布希德。这对夫妇最后一次被活捉是近两年前的1991年12月在悉尼
Kings Cross area almost two years earlier in December 1991. Anja had been stabbed multiple times in the torso and had also been decapitated with a single powerful blow to the back of the neck by a machete, sword, or axe. Despite extensive searches of the surrounding area, her skull was never recovered. Gabor had been shot in the back of the head six times and his hyoid bone was fractured, likely caused by forceful pressure applied to his neck in an act of strangulation. He was gagged with a piece of material that appeared to have been torn from a child's dress or apron. Curiously, the gag had been tied using a reef knot, which was of particular interest to investigators, as the knot used to tie the gag on Joanne Walters was done using a simple
国王十字（Kings Cross）地区的旅舍退房时。安雅的躯干被多次刺伤，并且被一把大砍刀、剑或斧头从后颈部强力一击斩首。尽管对周边地区进行了广泛搜索，她的头骨却从未被找到。加博尔的后脑勺被枪击了六次，他的舌骨骨折，很可能是由于在勒死行为中对他的颈部施加了强力压力造成的。他的嘴被一块似乎是从儿童连衣裙或围裙上撕下来的布料塞住。奇怪的是，塞口布是用平结打的，这引起了调查人员的特别兴趣，因为用来绑住乔安妮·沃尔特斯口布的结是用简单的
over-under pool knot. The two knot varieties hinted that it was possible more than one person was involved in the crimes. Dr. Peter Bradhurst, a forensic pathologist from the New South Wales Institute of Forensic Medicine, had been responsible for conducting the post-mortem examinations of all seven Balingolo victims. He noted significant differences as the killings progressed. The first three victims, James Gibson, Deborah Everest, and Simone Schmiddle, had been subject to blunt force trauma and frenzied stabbings. Later, Anya Habsheed, Gabor Neugebauer, Joanne Walters, and Caroline Clark had also been violently stabbed, but the killer had escalated to include shootings and a decapitation. As news spread that the Balingolo murder
上下交错拉结打的。这两种结的品种暗示了犯罪可能涉及不止一个人。彼得·布拉德赫斯特博士（Dr. Peter Bradhurst），来自新南威尔士州法医学研究所（New South Wales Institute of Forensic Medicine）的法医病理学家，负责对所有七名巴兰戈洛受害者进行尸检。随着杀戮的进展，他注意到了显着的差异。前三名受害者詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗里斯特和西蒙妮·施米德尔遭受了钝力外伤和疯狂的刺杀。后来，安雅·哈布希德、加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔、乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克也被残忍地刺伤，但凶手升级了作案手法，增加了枪击和斩首。随着巴兰戈洛谋杀
count had risen, Superintendent Clive Small fronted the media, commenting, I think it would be fair to say that given we now have seven bodies, that we do have a serial killer. There are obvious similarities. The distance from the road, the distance between the bodies, the manner in which they were covered, and the fact that they have been there for some time would lead us at this stage to conclude they are connected. Four bullets recovered from Gabor Neugebauer's remains were shot from a .22 caliber rifle, the same type of firearm used against Caroline Clark. The remaining two bullets had left his skull from the same exit wound, but couldn't be located at the crime scene despite police sifting
案死亡人数上升的消息传开，克莱夫·小总督察面对媒体评论说，我认为可以公平地说，鉴于我们现在有了七具尸体，我们的确有一名连环杀手。有明显的相似之处。距离道路的距离、尸体之间的距离、它们被掩盖的方式，以及它们在那里呆了一段时间的事实，将使我们在这个阶段得出结论：它们是有关联的。从加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔遗骸中回收的四颗子弹是由一支.22口径步枪发射的，这是针对卡洛琳·克拉克使用的同类型枪械。其余两颗子弹从他的头骨同一个出口伤口射出，但尽管警方进行了筛选，却无法在犯罪现场找到。
the soil and employing the use of metal detectors. This led to the belief Gabor was shot elsewhere in the bushland. Approximately 160 meters from Gabor and Anya's crime scene was a location investigators named Area A, a space which appeared to have been used by the killer as a shooting gallery. Here, police uncovered 47 used .22 caliber Winchester brand cartridge shells, along with an empty Winchester brand winner model ammunition box. Ballistic experts concluded these bullets were fired from a .22 caliber Ruger self-loading rifle with a 10 round rotary magazine, and it was the same firearm used against both Gabor Neugebauer and Caroline Clark. There were also 46 spent .22 caliber Ealy brand cartridges and an empty Ealy brand ammunition
土壤并使用金属探测器。这让人相信加博是在灌木丛的其他地方被枪杀的。距离加博和安妮案发现场大约 160 米处，有一个被调查人员命名为 A 区的地方，这个地方似乎被凶手用作射击靶场。在这里，警方发现了 47 枚用过的 .22 口径温彻斯特品牌弹壳，以及一个空的温彻斯特品牌赢家型号弹药盒。弹道专家得出结论，这些子弹是从一把带有 10 发旋转弹匣的 .22 口径鲁格半自动步枪中发射的，这与针对加博·纽格堡和卡罗琳·克拉克的凶器是同一把。现场还发现了 46 枚用过的 .22 口径伊利品牌弹壳和一个空的伊利品牌弹药
box. The Ealy bullets were determined to have been discharged from a different firearm, an Anschutz .22 caliber bolt action rifle. This meant two rifles were fired within Area A, a Ruger and Anschutz, with the varied locations of all 93 bullets indicating the guns were discharged from several directions in a concentric circle. Further examination revealed the guns were fired at or about the same time, ruling out the possibility that the killer or anyone else had returned to the scene at a later date to fire the second gun. Gauge marks on some of the bullets indicated a solancer had been attached to at least the Ruger to mitigate the risk of being heard. Bullets were found embedded in tree trunks while others were in the soil amongst the
盒。经确定，伊利子弹是从另一支火器发射的，即安舒茨 .22 口径栓动步枪。这意味着在 A 区内发射了两支步枪，即鲁格步枪和安舒茨步枪，所有 93 发子弹的不同位置表明，这些枪是从同心圆内的几个不同方向发射的。进一步检查显示，这些枪是在同一时间或大约同一时间发射的，从而排除了凶手或其他人日后返回现场发射第二支枪的可能性。某些子弹上的划痕表明，至少鲁格步枪上安装了消音器，以降低被听到的风险。子弹被发现嵌入树干中，而其他子弹则夹杂在
broken beer and cordial bottles, suggesting the shooter had used the glass bottles as target practice. The Ballistics team used the batch numbers from the empty Winchester and Ealy cartridge boxes found at Area A to try and narrow down the hunt for the owner of the weapons, but it was like searching for a needle in a haystack. The batch of Winchester cartridges comprised of 320,000 bullets which had been sold to over 55 outlets across Australia between June and November 1988, one year before the first of the Belangelo victims went missing. The Ealy brand ammunition had been manufactured and distributed in March 1979, almost a decade earlier, and their manufacturer had no records of which retail outlets the Ealy ammunition had gone to for sale.
破碎的啤酒和甜酒瓶中，这表明枪手曾用玻璃瓶进行打靶练习。弹道团队利用在 A 区发现的空的温彻斯特和伊利弹药盒上的批号，试图缩小搜寻武器所有者的范围，但这就像大海捞针。温彻斯特弹药批次包括 32 万发子弹，这些子弹在 1988 年 6 月至 11 月期间（即第一名贝兰格洛受害者失踪前一年）售给了澳大利亚各地的 50 多家零售店。伊利品牌弹药于 1979 年 3 月生产并分销，几乎早了十年，其制造商没有关于伊利弹药销往哪些零售店的记录。
With each new discovery investigators learned more insight into the mindset and patterns of the killer or killers. All crime scenes shared noticeable similarities with each victim having endured equally violent ordeals at the hands of a perpetrator who seemed to derive gratification from the torment of others. This was clear in a distinct stab wound some of the victims sustained to their backs, which would have rendered them paralyzed but kept them alive and conscious during subsequent torture. The extent of the perpetrator's depravity was further evident in his treatment of using several victims for target practice, shooting at them whilst they were restrained, with the wounds of at least one victim indicating they were repositioned several times before the
随着每一个新发现，调查人员对凶手或凶手的心态和模式有了更深入的了解。所有犯罪现场都有明显的相似之处，每个受害者都在凶手手中经历了同样暴力的磨难，凶手似乎从折磨他人中获得快感。这一点从一些受害者背部遭受的独特刺伤中可以看出，这会使他们瘫痪，但在随后的折磨中保持清醒和有意识。从凶手将几个受害者用作靶场练习对象的做法中，进一步证明了凶手行为的堕落，他们在受害者被束缚时向他们开枪，至少一名受害者的伤口表明他们在
firing recommenced. The disarray of some victims clothing from shirts pulled up to missing pants and underwear that investigators to believe they were also sexually interfered with. In each case the bodies of the victims were concealed under light scrub within 200 meters of a fire trail in the north region of the forest. They were all found lying face down against a rock or fallen tree covered by branches, twigs and forest debris, with the exception of James Gibson who was found laying on his side in the fetal position. Some officers believed there was a ritualistic pattern to the way each victim was buried, while others believed the positioning of each suggested the killer was neat, tidy and well organized. As the murders progressed,
开火重新开始前被多次重新调整位置。一些受害者衣服凌乱，从拉起的衬衫到不见了的裤子和内衣，让调查人员认为他们也受到了性侵犯。在每起案件中，受害者尸成都藏在森林北部火道 200 米内的轻矮树丛下。除了詹姆斯·吉布森被发现以胎儿姿势侧卧外，他们都被发现面朝下躺在岩石或倒下的树上，身上盖着树枝、小树枝和森林残骸。一些警官认为每个受害者的埋葬方式都有某种仪式感，而另一些警官则认为每个受害者的摆放位置表明凶手整洁、有条理。随着谋杀案的进行，
the attacks increased in brutality, becoming more cruel and vicious. The killer also became more brazen and confident, seemingly spending longer at the crime scene with each new victim. The first victims James Gibson and Deborah Everest were buried deep within the natural forest, but the second Simone Schmidl had been buried a little closer to the pine plantations, followed by Anya Habsheed and Gabor Neugebauer, who were buried closer again. From there it appeared the killer realized that they were edging too close to the pine plantations, which were frequented by forestry workers, so he returned deeper into the forest with Joanne Maltes and Caroline Clark. Superintendent Clive Small
袭击变得越来越残酷，变得更加残忍和恶毒。凶手也变得更加厚颜无耻和自信，随着每一个新受害者的出现，他在犯罪现场停留的时间似乎越来越长。第一名受害者詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里特被埋在天然森林深处，但第二名受害者西蒙妮·施米德尔被埋在离松树林更近一点的地方，接着是安妮·哈布希德和加博·纽格堡，他们被埋得更近了。从那里开始，凶手似乎意识到他们离伐木工人常去的松树林太近了，于是他和乔安妮·马尔特斯以及卡罗琳·克拉克的尸体一起回到了森林深处。总警司克莱夫·斯莫尔
quote, I think the sites have been deliberately chosen in the sense that they are all similar locations in terms of geography and conditions. We found a pattern to the extent that they appear to follow the perimeter of the pine forest. All we can do is follow the patterns. The discovery of makeshift fire pits close to each crime scene suggested two scenarios, that the killer lured their victims into the bush under the guise of offering them a genuine Aussie camping experience, charming them over the campfire before launching into an attack, or the killer camped at each scene after carrying out his crimes to relish the moment. Some found it hard to imagine a single offender could abduct, restrain, torture,
引述说，我认为这些地点是经过深思熟虑才选择的，因为它们在地理和条件方面都是相似的。我们发现了一种模式，即它们似乎沿着松林的外围延伸。我们所能做的就是遵循这些模式。每个犯罪现场附近发现的简易火坑暗示了两种可能的情况：凶手以提供真正澳大利亚露营体验为幌子，将受害者引诱到灌木丛中，在篝火旁用魅力征服他们，然后发动袭击；或者凶手在作案后在每个现场露营，以回味那一刻。有些人觉得很难想象一个单一的罪犯能够绑架、束缚、折磨、
and kill the victims traveling in pairs. One explanation was that the killer simply controlled his targets at gunpoint, while another speculated that the victims may have been drugged, with one of the pair killed in this incapacitated state, whilst the other was kept alive and tortured. Some experts even theorized that the killer may have forced one victim to inflict injury or death upon the other. There was also evidence to enhance the multi-perpetrator theory, from the two different firearms being used in conjunction at area A, to the two distinct knot styles used for gags and restraints, as well as the different methods of killing. As at least one victim was repositioned and fired upon in a target practice style setup, it seemed plausible that as one
并杀死结伴同行的受害者。一种解释是，凶手只是用枪口控制目标；另一种推测是，受害者可能被下了药，其中一人在这种丧失行为能力的状态下被杀害，而另一人则活着并遭受折磨。一些专家甚至推测，凶手可能迫使一名受害者对另一名受害者造成伤害或死亡。还有证据支持多人作案理论，从 A 区联合使用的两种不同的火器，到用于堵嘴和束缚的两种不同的结绳风格，以及不同的杀害方法。由于至少有一名受害者被重新调整位置并在打靶练习式的设置中被枪击，这似乎是合理的，即当一个
shooter fired, the other was responsible for moving the victim's body. Of the victim's belongings, only a small amount of clothing and personal effects were recovered from the crime scenes. The backpacks of Debra, Simone, Gabor, Anya, Joanne, and Caroline were still missing and contained a large array of clothes, cooking equipment, tents, sleeping bags, as well as a collection of foreign currency. James Gibson's backpack had been found at Galston Gorge over 100 kilometers away, but it was empty of most of his possessions. Having concluded they were dealing with the killer characterized by power and control, investigators believed it possible that at least some of the victim's belongings had been kept by him as trophies. They believed that once
枪手开枪时，另一个负责移动受害者的尸体。在受害者的财物中，从犯罪现场只找回了少量的衣物和个人物品。黛布拉、西蒙妮、加博、安妮、乔安妮和卡罗琳的背包仍然下落不明，里面装着大量的衣服、烹饪设备、帐篷、睡袋以及收集的外币。詹姆斯·吉布森的背包是在 100 多公里外的加尔斯顿峡谷被发现的，但里面大部财产都不见了。在断定他们面对的是一个以权力和控制为特征的凶手后，调查人员认为，至少部分受害者的财物可能被他当作战利品留下了。他们相信一旦
they found the killer, there was a good chance they would find the missing items. The Belangalo case had already become the biggest serial killing spree in New South Wales history, and Superintendent Clive Small was aware there may be more victims out there, saying, if you'd asked me this time last month whether there were any more bodies in the forest, I would never have expected to be back here talking about seven bodies. There are clearly other backpackers missing, and we have files and a whole range of people. A team of intelligence analysts reviewed over 600 unresolved missing person cases dating back to 1972, narrowing the list down to 20 they believed would be connected to the Belangalo serial killer.
他们找到了凶手，他们很有可能会找到失踪的物品。贝兰格洛案已经成为新南威尔士州历史上最大的连环杀人案，总警司克莱夫·斯莫尔意识到森林里可能还有更多的受害者，他说，如果你上个月这个时候问我森林里是否还有更多的尸体，我绝不会想到会回到这里谈论七具尸体。显然还有其他背包客失踪，我们有档案和各种各样的人。一组情报分析师审查了自 1972 年以来 600 多起未决失踪人员案件，将名单缩小到他们认为与贝兰格洛连环杀手有关的 20 起。
Interstate law enforcement also checked their backlog of case files, forwarding on any they suspected could be linked to Belangalo, with 25 arriving from Victoria Police and another six from Queensland Police. Duncan Chappell, director of the Australian Institute of Criminology, told The Age newspaper, I don't think that the killer would have killed only seven people. I suspect there is no reason why he would have stopped. They don't stop unless they are caught. I have never heard of therapy or anything else stopping serial killers. They may be very sociopathic, but they are not insane. The likelihood is that he has either killed more people, or is planning future killings.
州际执法部门也检查了他们的积压案件档案，转发了他们怀疑可能与贝兰格洛有关的案件，其中 25 起来自维多利亚警方，另外 6 起来自昆士兰警方。澳大利亚犯罪学研究所所长邓肯·查普尔在接受《时代报》采访时表示，我认为凶手不会只杀七个人。我怀疑他没有任何理由停手。除非被抓住，否则他们不会停手。我从未听说过治疗或其他任何事情能阻止连环杀手。他们可能非常反社会，但他们并不疯狂。很有可能他要么杀过更多的人，要么正在策划未来的谋杀。
On November 5th, the New South Wales government announced that a reward of $500,000 was on offer for anyone with information leading to the arrest and conviction of the Belangalo serial killer. This was a significant increase to the existing reward of $100,000 made available following the discovery of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark, and was on par with the highest reward ever offered in the state. The New South Wales Police Commissioner announced that a further 300 police would be added to the group of officers currently scouring Belangalo, and that the search would be extended to cover the entire perimeter of the 40 square kilometre forest. As the investigation expanded, a shed at the back of the Bowerall police station was converted to form the base of
11 月 5 日，新南威尔士州政府宣布悬赏 50 万澳元，征集提供线索以协助逮捕和定罪贝兰格洛连环杀手的线索。这比在发现乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克后提供的现有 10 万澳元悬赏金有了显著增加，与该州历史上提供的最高悬赏金持平。新南威尔士州警察局长宣布，将再增加 300 名警察加入目前在贝兰格洛搜寻的警官队伍，并且搜寻范围将扩大到覆盖整个 40 平方公里森林的外围。随着调查的扩大，保罗警察局后院的一个棚屋被改造成
operations for one half of Task Force Air, with the remaining officers working out of Sydney City. For lead detective Superintendent Clive Small, one of the biggest challenges they faced was information management. He was mindful of the investigation into the Yorkshire Ripper serial killings in the United Kingdom during the late 70s, covered in episode 37 of Case File. In that instance, several people had named the perpetrator to police throughout the investigation, but due to the way this vital information was mishandled, it was overlooked. Superintendent Small wanted to learn from these mistakes and ensure nothing of importance from the Belangalo serial killer case slipped through the cracks. Several investigations were now being consolidated under
“空气”特遣部队一半人员的行动基地，其余警官在悉尼市办公。对于首席侦探总警司克莱夫·斯莫尔来说，他们面临的最大挑战之一是信息管理。他注意到了 70 年代末英国对约克郡开膛手连环杀人案的调查，该案已在《案件档案》第 37 期中报道。在那起案件中，几名嫌疑人在整个调查过程中向警方指认了凶手，但由于处理这些至关重要信息的方式不当，它被忽视了。斯莫尔总警司希望从这些错误中吸取教训，确保贝兰格洛连环杀手案中任何重要的事情都不会被漏掉。现在有几项调查正在被合并在
Task Force Air, including the original missing person investigations of the seven known victims, as well as other missing persons who also may have fallen victim to the Belangalo serial killer. It was a logistical nightmare, as each missing person's case had been handled by police departments from different regions, with each having their own specific way of collating information. Some documents were only available in hard copy and stored within the police station of origin, while others were entered onto digital databases that couldn't be cross-referenced with other systems. Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark's murder investigation alone had generated more than seven and a half thousand inquiries, with over 500 people questioned. All that information had been
“空气”特遣部队下，包括七名已知受害者的原始失踪人员调查，以及可能也成为贝兰格洛连环杀手受害者的其他失踪人员。这是一场后勤噩梦，因为每个失踪人员的案件都由来自不同地区的警察部门处理，每个部门都有自己收集信息的特定方式。有些文件只有纸质版，存放在原籍警察局，而另一些则输入到无法与其他系统进行交叉比对的数字数据库中。仅乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的谋杀案调查就产生了七千五百多起查询，并讯问了五00多人。所有这些信息都被
stored on the New South Wales Police Task Force Information Management System, which was designed for standalone investigations and not equipped to handle the massive increasing scale that was the Belangalo case. The existing Task Force Management System was also unable to search records from government agencies, interstate police departments, or the Australian Federal Police. Recognizing this deficiency, Superintendent Small worked with intelligence analysts, data management experts, and software specialists to develop a more sophisticated system capable of handling the unique requirements of Task Force Air. They combined elements from 12 existing software packages to create an advanced system that enabled them to record, mine, and cross-reference
存储在新南威尔士州警察特遣部队信息管理系统中，该系统专为独立调查而设计，无法应对贝兰格洛案如此规模的巨大增长。现有的特遣部队管理系统也无法搜索来自政府机构、州际警察部门或澳大利亚联邦警察的记录。认识到这一缺陷，斯莫尔总警司与情报分析师、数据管理专家和软件专家合作，开发了一个更复杂的系统，能够处理“空气”特遣部队的独特要求。他们结合了 12 个现有软件包的元素，创建一个先进的系统，使他们能够记录、挖掘和交叉比对
data from a variety of sources, naming this new system Netmap. Importing all the existing data from the various old systems into the advanced Netmap database was a painstaking and time-consuming process. It caused short-term delays for investigators who were temporarily unable to access information, but the payoff was worth the wait. With Netmap up and running, more than one million pieces of information, including names, addresses, dates, locations, and vehicle details, could be cross-referenced with ease, saving potentially hundreds of hours of work for Task Force investigators. On November 16, police orchestrated a second search of Galston Gorge, the area two hours drive north of Belangelo, where James Gibson's camera
来自各种来源的数据，并将这个新系统命名为 Netmap。将来自各种旧系统所有现有数据导入高级 Netmap 数据库是一个艰苦且耗时的过程。这给调查人员造成了短期延误，他们暂时无法访问信息，但回报是值得等待的。随着 Netmap 的启动和运行，超过一百万条信息（包括姓名、地址、日期、地点和车辆详细信息）可以轻松交叉比对，可能为特遣部队调查人员节省数百小时的工作量。11 月 16 日，警方对加尔斯顿峡谷（贝兰格洛以北两小时车程的地区，詹姆斯·吉布森的相机
and backpack were found. The media speculated that the killer may have another burial ground in the surrounding Barara Valley Regional Park, although police insisted they weren't looking for more bodies, but rather for evidence relating to the seven confirmed victims. A team of over 100 police officers combed the designated four-kilometer area of rugged bushland either side of Galston Gorge Road, scouring the scrubbed shoulder-to-shoulder, while police divers searched the waters of nearby Barara Creek. A number of items were recovered, including a shirt, shoes, and a purse. The items were all examined by forensic experts, who determined them to be unrelated to any of the Belangelo victims. Meanwhile, the ongoing search of Belangelo State Forest had become one of the
和背包就是在这里被找到的）进行了第二次搜查。媒体推测凶手可能在周围的巴拉拉峡谷区域公园有另一个墓地，尽管警方坚称他们不是在寻找更多尸体，而是在寻找与七名确证受害者有关的证据。由 100 多名警察组成的团队梳理了加尔斯顿峡谷路两侧指定的四公里崎岖灌木丛区域，肩并肩地搜寻矮树丛，而水警潜水员则搜寻了附近巴拉拉溪的水域。寻获了许多物品，包括衬衫、鞋子和钱包。这些物品都经过了法医专家的检查，他们确定这些物品与任何贝兰格洛受害者无关。与此同时，对贝兰格洛州立森林的持续搜查已成为
largest ever conducted in Australia's criminal history. Despite this, no further evidence or bodies were located, and police felt confident there was nothing else to be found. On November 16, 1993, the intensive search of Belangelo finally reached its conclusion. The 400 officers who had conducted the search bowed their heads and observed a moment's silence in memory of the victims. A police chaplain recited the Lord's Prayer before lamenting. We are reminded of the fragility of life as we remember those seven young people whose life was brief and who died in such tragic circumstances. An article penned by journalist Frank Walker for newspaper The Sydney Morning Herald spoke of the eerie silence that haunted Belangelo since
澳大利亚犯罪史上规模最大的搜查之一。尽管如此，没有发现更多的证据或尸体，警方确信没有其他东西可找。1993 年 11 月 16 日，对贝兰格洛的密集搜查终于结束。进行搜查的 400 名警官低下头，默哀片刻，以缅怀受害者。一名海军牧师背诵了主祷文，然后悲叹道。当我们缅怀这七位生命短暂、在如此悲惨的情况下死去的年轻人时，我们被提醒生命的脆弱性。记者弗兰克·沃克为《悉尼先驱晨报》撰写的一篇文章谈到了自
the murders of James Gibson, Deborah Everest, Simone Schmiddle, Gabor Neugebauer, Anya Habschede, Joanne Walters, and Caroline Clark. He wrote, It makes the skin crawl to walk the trails of this creepy place, taking the same path that the killer or killers of seven young backpackers must have taken as he delivered them to their appointment with death. No birds fly from the stringy bark gum trees. No animals scurry away in the bushes. Something is terribly wrong here. As the search of the forest slowly drew to an end, the media reported that up to 20 people were being looked at as potential persons of interest in the Belangelo killings, but police had yet to establish any firm suspects. The search for the
詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗里特、西蒙妮·施米德尔、加博·纽格堡、安妮·哈布谢德、乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克遇害以来一直困扰着贝兰格洛的怪异寂静。他写道，走在这个毛骨悚然的地方的小径上，走着七名年轻背包客的凶手或凶手带他们走向死亡时必定走过的小路，让人起鸡皮疙瘩。没有鸟儿从纤皮桉树上飞过。灌木丛中没有动物仓皇逃窜。这里有什么地方出了大问题。随着对森林搜查的慢慢接近尾声，媒体报道有多达 20 人被视为贝兰格洛谋杀案的潜在受关注人员，但警方尚未确定任何坚定的嫌疑人。搜寻
Ruger and Dan Schultz rifles used in Belangelo were still underway, with the US manufacturer of the Ruger stating that tens of thousands of the firearms had been imported into Australia, meaning identifying the owner of one of them would be no easy feat. However, ballistic experts were able to narrow the search down slightly as the base of one of the spent cartridges recovered from the crime scene had an upward indentation. This was caused by a known fault in the firing pins of Ruger's made between 1964 and 1982. Task Force Air obtained the manufacturer's records and created a database of all Ruger rifles that had been imported into Australia. They then acquired the Australian Federal Police database that listed all licensed the Ruger owners in the country.
贝兰格洛使用的鲁格和安舒茨步枪仍在进行中，鲁格的美国制造商表示，已有数万支这种枪支进口到澳大利亚，这意味着要确定其中一支的所有者并非易事。然而，弹道专家能够将搜查范围稍微缩小，因为从犯罪现场回收的一枚用过的弹壳底部有一个向上的压痕。这是由 1964 年至 1982 年间制造的鲁格击针中已知的故障引起的。“空气”特遣部队获得了制造商的记录，并创建了所有进口到澳大利亚的鲁格步枪的数据库。然后，他们获得了澳大利亚联邦警察局的数据库，其中列出了国内所有持牌鲁格所有者。
This database had been created by the AFP following the 1989 murder of former Assistant Federal Police Commissioner Colin Winchester, who was shot dead with a .22 caliber semi-automatic Ruger rifle fitted with a silencer. Task Force Air ruled out all Ruger rifles that were already in police possession or had been destroyed as of December 1991, the first time the firearm was used against a Balingolo victim. Detectives then questioned licensed firearm holders, gun clubs and checked gun shop records. They doorknocked houses of registered gun owners in the southern Highlands area and seized all Ruger rifles to conduct ballistic comparisons. Superintendent Clive Small from his book Inside Australia's Biggest Manhunt quote,
该数据库是联邦警察局在 1989 年前联邦警察助理专员科林·温彻斯特被谋杀后创建的，他被一把装有消音器的 .22 口径半自动鲁格步枪枪杀。特遣部队排除了所有截至 1991 年 12 月（即该枪首次用于贝兰格洛受害者时）已经由警方拥有或已被销毁的鲁格步枪。然后，侦探们讯问了持枪执照持有者、枪械俱乐部，并检查了枪店记录。他们走访了南部高地地区的注册枪支所有者的房屋，并没收了所有鲁格步枪以进行弹道比对。克莱夫·斯莫尔总警司在他的书《走进澳大利亚最大的人搜捕》中引用道，
Working from the top down and at the bottom up would, we hoped, enable us to identify both the number of unaccounted four Ruger's and a number of people who could not account for their Ruger. The two-pronged strategy ought to expose emissions and highlight mismatches while allowing us to narrow the focus to specific geographic areas and to individual gun owners who could not be eliminated. It was laborious and time-consuming, but we were not in a race. After inspecting over two and a half thousand registered firearms from residents throughout New South Wales, police were yet to uncover the weapon they were looking for. Police had since launched a toll-free hotline for members of the public to phone in with
我们希望，从上到下和从下到上的工作将使我们能够识别出未清查的鲁格步枪数量以及无法解释其鲁格去向的人数。双管齐下的策略应该会暴露遗漏并突出不匹配，同时使我们能够将重点缩小到特定的地理区域和无法被排除在外的个人枪主持有者。这很费力且耗时，但我们并非在赛跑。在检查了新南威尔士州各地居民的二千五百多支注册枪支后，警方尚未找到他们正在寻找的武器。此后，警方为公众开通了一个免费热线，供民众拨打提供
information or tips. It received an overwhelming response, with over 5,000 calls made in the first 24 hours from all over Australia and overseas. Details from every single call were entered into the database, with a printout of each handed to an investigator to be assigned one of three classifications. No action, due course or priority one. Superintendent Small was mindful that the seemingly insignificant detail could be the clue needed to identify the killer. But with so many tips coming through, it was not always immediately clear which ones took priority. One woman phoned to report a man she knew whose family owned a property in the Southern Highlands region, not too far from Belangelo. She had been compelled to provide his details
信息或线索。它得到了压倒性的回应，在头 24 小时内就接到了来自澳大利亚各地和海外的 5,000 多个电话。来自每个电话的详细信息都被输入到数据库中，每通电话的打印件都会交由调查人员分配三种分类之一。不采取行动，适时处理或第一优先级。斯莫尔总警司注意到，看似微不足道的细节可能是识别凶手所需的线索。但随着如此多的线索涌入，并不总是能立即弄清楚哪些优先。一名女性打电话来报告她认识的一个男人，他的家人在南部高地地区拥有房产，离贝兰格洛不远。她被迫提供他的详细信息
to the hotline purely on the basis that he owned a four-wheel drive vehicle and had a keen interest in firearms, owning several. The call operator took his name, Ivan Malat, and the information was entered onto the database as per protocol. Another call came into the hotline from a woman based in South West Sydney, identified as Mary. She wanted to report an incident that happened near 16 years earlier that bore chilling similarities to the circumstances of the recent Belangelo crimes. In July 1977, when Mary and her friend Therese were 18 years old, they were hitchhiking south along the Hume Highway, hoping for a ride back home to Canberra. The pair were picked up by a man with black straggly hair who appeared to be aged in his 30s.
给热线纯粹是因为他拥有四轮驱动车辆并且对枪械有着浓厚的兴趣，拥有好几支。接线员记下了他的名字伊万·马莱特，并按协议将信息输入数据库。另一通电话打到热线，来自悉尼西南部的一名女性，身份被确认为玛丽。她想报告一起发生在近 16 年前的事件，该事件与最近贝兰格洛罪行的环境惊人相似。1977 年 7 月，当玛丽和她的朋友特蕾西 18 岁时，他们沿着休姆高速公路向南搭便车，希望能搭车回堪培拉的家。两人被一个黑发蓬乱、看起来三十多岁的男人接走了。
As he drove the young women along the Hume Highway, the driver suddenly took a right turn near the Southern Highlands town of Mitigong, explaining it was a shortcut. Once they reached an isolated dirt road, he pulled the car over under the guys of needing a toilet brake before grabbing Mary by the arm and saying, Okay girls, who's first? Mary fought him off, and she and Therese managed to escape, running into the surrounding bushland where they hid under some shrubbery. The men searched for them over the following hours, slowly driving up and down the dirt road. Upon failing to find the women, he gave up and left. Shaken, Mary and Therese sought help from the occupants of a nearby farmhouse who offered to drive them to Bowerall
当他开车带着年轻女性沿着休姆高速公路行驶时，司机突然在南部高地城镇米蒂贡附近向右转，解释说这是一条捷径。一旦他们到达一条偏僻的泥土路，他就在需要上厕所为借口的情况下把车停在路边，然后抓住玛丽的手臂说，好了姑娘们，谁先来？玛丽反抗了他，她和特蕾西设法逃脱了，跑进了周围的灌木丛，躲在一些灌木丛下。这个男人在接下来的几个小时里搜寻他们，慢慢地沿着泥土路上下开车。在没能找到这些女性后，他放弃并离开了。受到惊吓的玛丽和特蕾西向附近农舍的住户寻求帮助，他们提出开车送他们去鲍罗尔
police station, but they declined, choosing not to report the matter. Mary's story was corroborated by her friend Therese, who also placed a call to the hotline later that day to report the same distressing incident that occurred back in 1977. A week after the hotline received the harrowing calls from Mary and Therese, a woman from Canberra named Joanne Berry phoned in to report yet another disturbing incident that took place on the Hume Highway. This one three years earlier, in January 1990. One month after James Gibson and Deborah Everest went missing, Joanne was driving her Toyota Tarago van south down the Hume Highway, when just before the
警察局，但他们拒绝了，选择不举报此事。玛丽的故事得到了她的朋友特蕾西的证实，特蕾西也在当天晚些时候给热线打电话，报告了 1977 年发生的那起令人痛苦的事件。在热线接到玛丽和特蕾西令人毛骨悚然的电话一周后，堪培拉一名叫乔安妮·贝里的女性打电话来报告休姆高速公路上发生的又一起令人不安的事件。这一次是三年前的 1990 年 1 月。在詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里特失踪一个月后，乔安妮正驾驶着她的丰田塔拉戈面包车沿休姆高速公路向南行驶，就在
turnoff to Balangalo State Forest, she noticed two men scuffling on the side of the road. One was violently pushing the other to the ground, and a silver four-wheel drive vehicle was pulled over nearby. The younger man sustaining the attack managed to escape the grip of his assailant, allowing him the opportunity to flee. He raced up the highway frantically signalling for help, jumping in front of Joanne's car as she approached, giving her no choice but to stop. He then rushed around to the door of the van before pulling it open and leaping inside. Joanne ordered the stranger to get out of her vehicle, but he yelled back in a British accent, I'm not getting out, he's got a gun. His distress was palpable, and Joanne instantly
通往贝兰格洛州立森林的岔路口前，她注意到路边有两个男人在推搡。一个人在暴力地将另一个人推倒在地，附近停着一辆银色的四轮驱动汽车。遭受袭击的年轻男子设法挣脱了袭击者的控制，从而有机会逃跑。他拼命地沿着高速公路狂奔，疯狂地挥手求救，并在乔安妮靠近时跳到她的车前，使她别无选择，只能停下来。然后他冲到面包车门前，拉开门跳了进去。乔安妮命令这个陌生人下车，但他用英国口音大喊道，我不下车，他有枪。他的痛苦显而易见，乔安妮立刻
understood the urgency of the situation. She saw a brake in the median strip, drove across it to perform a U-turn, then sped off in the opposite direction. As the Tarago headed towards Bowerall police station, its occupants caught sight of the young man's attacker out the van's rear window. He stood alone on the opposite side of the highway, staring right back at them, an evil smirk across his face. To be continued next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
明白了情况的紧迫性。她看到中央隔离带有缺口，便开过去掉头，然后以极快的速度朝着相反的方向驶去。当塔拉戈面包车驶向鲍罗尔警察局时，车内的人从面包车的后窗看到了年轻男子的袭击者。他独自站在高速公路的对侧，直勾勾地盯着他们，脸上带着邪恶的假笑。下周未完待续。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。